If I need something, I'll let you know.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
So yesterday we discussed the narration.
I'd to review it for the sake of
reflection, for the sake of
perfection. so that we can try to
examine some of the lessons
that are in this narration. This is the
narration of Jabb Abdah and this is u
regarding
and the author is listing instances and
occasions in which or circumstances that
warrant making
that make it permissible for a person to
use a as opposed to purification with
water. It's the narration of
He said, "We went out on a journey and a
man, one of us, a man amongst us was hit
with a rock in the head and it opened up
his head."
means that he got an injury to his head
that you know split his scalp open.
This could have been in the battle that
they went to. This could have been in
thewa that they went to. Most likely
this was just them passing through a
valley in in you know between
mountains and rocks rolled down from
above. for whatever reason.
The point is is that he got hit in the
head with a rock and he got very
seriously injured and in a few we will
see just how seriously he was injured.
So he fell asleep and he had a wet
dream. So now he wakes up and he's in a
state of janaba. And so
knowing that he had this injury and
knowing that he is unable to wash his
head, wash his hair, etc. the things
that go into bathing. He asked his close
companions, his traveling companions.
He asked them, "Do you think that I
would have an excuse to make
rather than bathing because of my
injury? Do you think that I have an
allowance to make a tu?" Now, the point
I want to make here, what is knowledge?
Knowledge is knowing the truth, knowing
reality, knowing the truth, knowing
something with its evidence. You have
evidence for it. This is knowledge.
These companions that were with him are
companions of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. But not all companions are the
same. Some of them are part of his inner
circle. Some of them are part of his
outer circle. Some of them have only
seen him in passing. Some of them are
companions. They're counted as
companions in the legislative sense, but
maybe they haven't even had a
conversation with him. Right? Not all
the companions are all scholars, and
even those that are close to him aren't
necessarily scholars. This is a very
particular type of person. And so these
companions are companions of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam but they're not the
scholars amongst them. Do they have
knowledge? Yes.
Because they know about
and they know the evidence from the
Quran. They know about bathing and woo
and purification for salah. They have
evidence for this. They know the verses
that are in the Quran regarding this.
However,
the knowledge that they have is under
normal circumstances.
That's the general shared knowledge
amongst regular people. Regular people
know that if I'm in a state of janaba, I
have to bathe. This is the general
knowledge. If a person has
circumstances that are not matching
with exactly
what is mentioned in the verses or the
narrations,
they have a set of circumstances that
are unique. This takes extra knowledge.
Now you have to know the parameters of
bathing. You have to know the allowances
of and this is something that they did
not have. They did not have this
Islam
that these companions whilst they
were companions and they have limited
general knowledge. However, the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam was angry
with them and made dua against them for
what they will later say because they
were not of the people authorized to
make it.
They are not authorized to make it.
Right? So
they said he said, "Do you think that I
could have a an allowance to make tow
of an allowance for you in this
circumstance
being that you have access to water,
being that you have access the water.
So this is the limit of their knowledge.
What should they have said? Allah.
What is knowledge really? It's two
parts. It's questions and their answers.
That's what knowledge is. Any piece of
knowledge is the question and its
answer. Its correct answer. Right? This
is really what knowledge is. And so if a
person does not have the answer to his
question,
he reverts back to the certain knowledge
and that is Allah.
And if a person does not learn this
lesson, they are a person of ignorance.
Even if they have facts and knowledge
and so forth, but they don't know their
own limitations.
What is the hallmark of a strong mind?
An intelligent person.
Intelligence
is a person being aware of his own self
and his own limitations.
The disbelievers, they rejected the
Quran. Correct? Why did they reject it?
because it raised questions and they
didn't have the answers to it. Some of
them Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
they disbelieved
in the truth
because they did not reach the
they they did not reach any kind of
depth of knowledge about it. They just
reject it based on the assumption that
it doesn't make sense to them.
Therefore, it can't make sense. It's not
true. If you don't understand it,
someone else will understand it. If you
don't have the answer, someone else may
have the answer. Rejecting something
something simply because you do not know
it or understand it. This is a hallmark
of ignorance. And so, this is what they
told him. and
says,
"So the man then went to bathe on their
advice and he died. He died of this." So
when they returned back to the to Medina
to the prophet Sam,
they killed him. May Allah kill them.
And this statement, may Allah kill them,
is a figure of speech, right?
Why didn't they ask if they didn't know?
For indeed, the remedy
to ignorance is question, is a sound
question. The remedy to ignorance is
asking.
He says it was sufficient. It was enough
for him to just make. So he was right.
Even though he was the minority,
correct? He was one and he in his best
judgment
his mind went to
the majority around him said no you need
to bathe. Who was right and who was
wrong? He was right and he was the
minority. Is it possible for the
minority to be correct in spite of the
majority's disagreement? Absolutely.
Yeah. Because true things do not become
more true the more people that believe
them or acknowledge them. And wrong
things
do not become more wrong because more
people deem them as such. Truth and and
and falsehood, right and wrong, these
are transcending transcendent
things. They don't need people to
believe in them for them to be right,
for them to be wrong. And this is why
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he tells us
He says to the prophet Sam,
"If you were to follow the majority of
the people on the earth, the majority,
they will misguide you and mislead you
off of the path of Allah." Subhan Allah.
Foreign